which portion of my money am I
comfortable losing a hundred percent of
that shouldn't be a big percentage you
could say only five percent fine so if
you're five percent is a hundred
thousand dollars fifty thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars a million
dollars you can afford putting in Risky
Investments that you may lose all of it
but you cannot lose sleep so if you're
the kind of a person that will lose
sleep if you lose that kind of money
don't do it because it's gonna mess with
you only do it if you know your
temperament investing is very different
for different people it's different for
you than my temperament than his
temperament and his temperament people
come to me and they say why are you
always sitting on so much cash and why
are you not deploying do you know how
much money that's costing you I said
that's my temperament because I'm able
to invest that money